you know what's crazy is that you have
been you're a very good stuntman stunt
double and you take that stuff seriously
you've been a stuntman and a body double
for your brother ah what's that
experience like getting dressed up like
your little brother is it's kind of
weird yeah I've had some interesting
moments yeah my one of the first times
my mother called me and you know just to
see how things were going and she's like
you're not letting Joel do anything
dangerous are you and I like what she
said we not letting Joel do anything
dangerous I said remember well it's okay
for me to do something that yes and she
said well yeah it's mom that's like if
we both drew a picture when we were
little kids and we handed them to you
and we asked you to pick a favorite yeah
and you actually picked one yes yeah
that's what she's saying she's pretty
much saying it's okay if you get hurt
she's just letting me know to my face
that he's the favorite yeah no I know
that I'm expendable I I know what I know
what that's like you've been in
situations where you've had to do a
really dangerous stunt where it looks
like your brother's doing it but then
he's doesn't do it he stopped he they
freeze the action you come in and then
you have to do the stunt yeah yeah tell
me describe what that's like
well one night in particular I uh I
remember was like it was night shoot on
a parking garage and I'm getting hit by
a car for him and so I've done the first
take I've been hit by the car so well
he's done is he's done a thing where
he's like oh yeah then they freeze yeah
and then I come in dressed like him his
brother yeah the car comes at high speed
hits me I smashed the windshield you
know land on the ground I'm bleeding
from my hand I've got glass in my hand
so they've got a bucket for me to bleed
into well a nurse has a vacuum and she
sucks the glass out of my hand so you're
there hand over a bucket bleeding into
it a vacuum cleaner is taking out and
then they're taking and you taking out
the broken windshield putting another
one because they want to do a second
take of it right and then I look over to
my right and
there's my brother with a blanket and a
hot chocolate chatting out this cute
makeup artists yeah sure
yeah and he's laughing and giggling and
yeah give me a little wife yeah and yeah
and then they get the gloss out and I'll
go and do it again yeah yeah yeah he got
the better he teaches a good gig he's
got a really a yeah
you